[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى وجهنا لوجه بين
علاقات تاريخيه راسخه مع موسكو تعود
جذورها للاصتافات الحرب البارده مصالح
وشراكات مستجده ومتجدده مع شركاء الغربيين
وعلى راسهم الاوروبيين وبين ضغوط متزايد
او حتى تهديدات بعقوبات ولا سيكما من
الولايات المتحده من اجل اداره الظهر
لروسيا في سياق الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
تتارجح الجزائر محاوله للحفاظ على توازن
قد يبدو شبه مستحيل ومؤكده ان عدم
الانحياز يبقى باوصلتها فهل الحجاز الذي
تصبو الجزائر اليه ممكن ام انها بالواقع
بدات تبدل مواقفها ولا سيما تجاهها الشريك
الروسي خاصه مع الحديث عن تاجيل المناورات
العسكريه التي كانت مرتقبه بين الجانبين
وهل ترضخ الجزائر لضغوط الغرب حفاظا على
مصالحها اسئله وغيرها اطرحها على ضيف ك
بدايه الدكتور عطوان بسبوس مدير مرصد
الدول العربيه في باريس اهلا بك معنا
ايضا على الجانب الاخر من الجزائر السيد
عمار صيغه الباحث في العلوم السياسيه
السيد عمار مرحبا
مرحبا بكم مرحبا
في هذا الموضوع
بالنظر الى تصويت الجزائر في الجمعيه
العامه للاممي المتحده بين التصويت الاول
في مارس وتصويت الذي جرى منذ ايام يبدو
الموقف ثابتا لكن المراقب للتفاصيل
والمدقق فيها سيرى بان هناك لغه حصل مؤخرا
بين باريس وروسيا تحديدا تاجيل زياره تبون
الى مايو المقبل تاجيل مناورات عسكريه
زيارات بطروشه في مقاله مؤخرا بشان
الشراكه التاريخيه بين الدولتين ما الذي
يحصل بين موسكو والجزائر
اعتقد انا تجربه اوكرانيا الحرب على
اوكرانيا محاوله غزو اوكرانيا الفاشله
بررت الى حد ما من من يعني صوره موسكو لدى
الجزائر فكان ينظر لروسيا كانها ورثه
الاتحاد السوفيتي الثاني قوه في العالم
يستند اليها معسكر تسانج وبتبيع السلاح
تبيع خبرات تدرب ضباطه واذا يكتشف
اقتصاديه ايضا شراكه اقتصاديه ولكن
بالاساس عسكريه اكثر من اي شيء اخر وفي
كذلك تصدير القمح والذره وهنالك ولكن
اكتشف العالم الذي كان يساند روسيا انها
انها يعني من ورق ليست ليست قويه ليست
قادره على
اجتياح دوله صغيره جانبها
لذلك يعني الى حد بعيد هناك عدد من الدول
اعادت وتعيد اليوم
النظر في علاقاتها وقربها من روسيا خاصه
ان روسيا لم هل الجزائر من هذه الدول
اعتقد انها من هذه الدول يعني
سلسال سلاح الجزائري مصدره روسيا واذا
اليوم نجد ان روسيا تشتري
الصواريخ
والطيارات المسيره من ايران من كوريا
الشماليه تبحث عن مصدر تمويل فائزه تنويع
ربما مصادر لا لانه الصناعات الروسيه لم
تكن مجديه ولم يعني تستطيع ان
تعطي الجيش العتاد الكافي فكيف بالتصدير
فاذا كل الدول التي
اعتمدت او او طلبت سلاحا من روسيا اليوم
تقول هل روسيا لا تكفي ذاتها وتشتري من
الخارج كيف ستلبي حاجاتنا من السلاح لذلك
روسيا يعني سنه منذ سنه
تبين انها النمر من ورق الى حد بعيد وعدد
من الدول ومن بينها الجزائر تعيد النظر في
نظرتها الى روسيا في تقييمها
مع روسيا سيد عمار في الجزائر ما رايك انت
هل ترى بان الجزائر بدات تعيد النظر في
علاقاتها مع روسيا استنادا الى مقاله ضيف
ايضا هنا في الاستوديو واستنادا الى
التفاصيل التي ذكرتها انا قبل قليل
انطلاقا من علاقات الجزائر المرتده في
التاريخ منذ استقلالها
وحتى الاستقلال اثناء الثوره التحريريه
علاقات توازن بين شركائها
سياسيين الذي تتقاطعهم في كثير من المبادئ
والاساسيه غير ان محطات هامه وفارقه في
العلاقات الدوليه وعلى على خلفيات الحرب
البارده جعلت الجزائر ربما
تمسك بمسافه الامان مع كل الاطراف ولذلك
في اطار منظمه عدم الامتياز وذلك كله حافظ
كذلك على سمعه الجزائر وعلى وزن على
سمعتها لدى كل شركاء الدوليين الجزائر وكل
المحطات التي
مررت فيها الدوليه
والمعده سقوط المعسكر الشيوعي في سنه 1989
وبروز ميل ثم بالقطبيه الاحاديه غير ان
الجزائر حافظت على المسافه
في اطار المواثيقه الدوليه الرواسب
المعروفه للحرب البارده السيد عمار ان
الجزائر كانت محسوبه على المعسكر الشرقيه
عاده يعني عطوه ذكرت ما قلته قبل قليل ما
الذي حدث حتى تتم تاجيل او يتم تاجيل
زياره تبون الى روسيا كانت مرتقبه في
ديسمبر الى مايو المقبل ما الذي حدث حتى
يحصل هذا اللقط في التصريحات بشان مقاله
موسكو بان المناوره العسكريه درع الصحراء
في الصحراء الجزائريه ستتم لكن الجزائر
نفذ ذلك ثم تم الحديث عن التاجيل زياره
باتروشيف التي جاءت كما يبدو لمحاوله
اصلاح ذات البين بين الدولتين كيف نفهم
هذه التطورات
اذا بعيد عن البحث في مطبات في التاريخ
الغابه دعينا الان نكون اكثر واقعيا
الجزائر الان تلعب على وتر التوازن في
علاقاتها بين مختلف القوى الفاعله الدوليه
وذلك بالمحافظه على مسافه الامان الجزائر
لا تريد نفسها مع اي طرف من وذلك يتجلى من
خلال مبدا
الحياد ومبدا التوازن في العلاقات هنا
وهنا نعتقد وهي برايك الان تتمكن من ذلك
تتمكن من الحفاظ على هذا التوازن
المؤكد هو كذلك هو هذا الانسان المتوازي
هناك انزال
قاده سياسين وامنين من موسكو في الجزائر
وكذلك بالمقابل هناك انزال دبلوماسي وامني
وعسكري للقاده دبلوماسيين وعسكريين
تماما محوريه الجزائر في الفعل الدولي
الراهن الجزائر حافظت على مسافه الامان
بين مختلف اصدقائها واؤكد الان على اصدقاء
لماذا لانها مبدا الصداقه في العلاقات
الدوليه الجزائريه
الا في حاله في حاله ما يتعلق بالسياده
الوطنيه ومتعلق بالاساسيات المتعلقه
بالامن القومي الجزائري فلا مجال للمناوره
في ذلك
هل تستطيع فعلا الجزائر الحفاظ على هذا
الحداد
اولا هناك حدث مناورات عسكريه روسيه
جزائريه
ثلاث مرات خلال الاشهر الاخيره مره في
المتوسط مره في فستق في في روسيا
وقيل ان مره في جنوب الجزائر ولكن لم يؤكد
هذا الخبر الاخير هلا بالنسبه للجزائر لا
تريد ان تكون محسوبه على معسكر معين ولكن
قلبها وتاريخها
وسلاحها وتدريب جيشها وعلاقاتها المتينه
هي مستمره مع موسكو ولكن اليوم موسكو لم
تعد ضمانه لاصدقائها لذلك نجد ان في
اوروبا اسبانيا المانيا النمسا اليوم
اصبحت في المحور المغربي ولذلك
الجزائر تريد التقرب من ايطاليا وهذا ما
حدث وربما الى الجزائر
ورئيس الحكومه الذي سبقها زار الجزائر
مرتين في في اقل من سنه وهناك تحريك
للعلاقه مع بريطانيا وكذلك مع فرنسا فلذلك
الجزائر لا تريد ان تكون محسوبه على فريق
تريد ان تبقي بيضها في عده سلال حتى لا
تحاصر بان مصالحها اليوم باتت مع الغرب مع
شركاء الغربيين خاصه في ظل هذه الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه ليس فقط لان لانها
موسكو ليست بتلك القوه لكن ايضا بالنسبه
للمصالح الاقتصاديه هي الان تحاول ان تعوض
موسكو اقتصاديا ولا استجابه بالنسبه
لسفقات الغاز مع الاوروبيين
المصلحه الجزائريه تختلف عن مصلحه روسيا
روسيا تريد ان تخنق الغرب وتعاقب بحرمان
من الغاز الروسي وجعله يعني
يبحث عن الغاز بكثافه الجزائر لا تستطيع
ان تعوض الغاز الروسي لانه ربما يكون في
باطن ارضها غاز كثير ولكن ما هو مستخرج
اليوم يصلح نصفه
[موسيقى]
للداخل يعني
الطهي وللمحركات
نفسها يعني ممول او يعني لا تستطيع ان
تعوض النقص الناتج من الغاز الروسي عليها
ان تستكشف ارضها ربما يكون هناك غاز
في المستقبل يمكن ان تكون يعني مصدر
واليوم تبحث من نيجيريا فيك ان تكون هب
يعني مركز تصدير الغاز الاتي من نيجيريا
يعني من بعد 3000 كيلو متر من حدودها لذلك
لا تريد ان تعتمد على موسكو الضعيفه اليوم
لذلك تنوع
علاقاتها في اوروبا وهنا ربما يكون دور
بريطانيا فرنسا ايطاليا يعود الى حد ما
المحور يعني موقفها متارجح بين المغرب
والجزائر هذا هذا سياق موضوع اخر هذا هذه
النظره مغاربيه المغرب يريد ان تكون فرنسا
الى جانب وضد الجزائر في حين الجزائر تريد
ان تكون فرنسا الى جانب وضد المغرب
الجزائر الان تجاوزت لعب الاوراق الامنيه
والعسكريه الان تلعب اوراق اقتصاديه اكثر
تقدما الان كل الاشخاص بانهم من هم بحاجه
اليها وليس هي من هي بحاجه اليهم
في صفوف الجيش الوطني الشعبي والان الجيش
الوطني الشعبي الجزائري اكثر احترافيه
واكثر واكثر بعدا عن مختلف ما يشبه من
صراعات او من خلافات داخل المؤسسه
العسكريه المؤسسه العسكريه
خلال ابتعادنا التام عن كل ما يتعلق
بالساحه السياسيه الجزائر الان قلنا تلعب
مقاربه اقتصاديه
جميعا انهم منهم بحاجه اليها هم الان
يتهافتون ويقومون بانزال
في الجزائر لان روسيا تعد شريكا عسكريا
مهما بالنسبه للجزائر تحدثنا عن المناورات
العسكريه نتحدث عن صفقات الاسلحه يعني هذه
نقطه وهذا عامل مهم في العلاقات بين
الدولتين
الموجوده بين المؤسسه العسكريه والجزائريه
في روسيا وذلك من خلال تقاطع المصالح خاصه
في الصناعات العسكريه وهناك سوق سوق
الروسيه واحده بالنسبه للشركه الجزائري في
حين انه ربما دروس الماضيه خاصه في
العشريه السوداء عندما الدول على نفسها
وتركت الجزائر لوحدها
تكافح في وجه الارهاب ولم تكن الا ترسلنا
الروسي في مواجهه هذا هذه الظاهره الغريبه
العسكريه الروسيه التي تم الحديث عنها
مؤخرا عن امكانيه
بنائها وترشيدها في الجنوب الجزائري ايضا
كان هناك لغت حول هذه النقطه
بان الخطاب السيد رئيس الجمهوريه قد قد
وقفت المتعلقه
قاعده عسكريه في الاراضي الجزائريه
وبالتالي يؤدي من الخطوط الحمراء ان تكون
هناك قاعده عسكريه اجماليه الجزائريه
لماذا لانه الجيش الجزائري الان اكثر
احترافيه وابان عن قدراته في معرفه كل
مختلف التهديدات سواء الاقليميه او
الداخليه وهذا ما يترجم ربما شركات
العسكريه لمختلف الدول والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه خاصه في مسار برشلونه في 1995
خسرا الى الاحداث الحادي عشر من سبتمبر
وبالتالي الجزائر
تلعب دورا محوريا في الساحل الافريقي وهي
كذلك تلعب دورا محورين في اعاده الامن
الافريقيه وهذا ما
يخالف اريحيه لدى شركاء الامنيين الغربيين
او في الشرق الصين الهند وروسيا الى غيرها
عود الى السيد الى الدكتور انطوان البسبوس
يعني المشكله مع المغرب مشكله الصحراء
الغربيه وسواق التسلح الذي نراه مؤخرا مع
المغرب هل يمكن ان يكون
هل يمكن ان يحكم بشكل او باخر العلاقات
بين الجزائر وشركائها سواء الغرب او من
الشرق يعني مثلا مساله القاعده العسكريه
الروسيه التي تم الحديث عنها في الجزائر
هل يمكن ان تحدث مقابل قاعده امريكيه مثلا
في المغرب
لا اعتقد ان الجزائر جاهزه لاعطاء روسيا
قاعده عسكريه اليوم خاصه ان روسيا موجوده
في مالي جارتها موجوده في ليبيا عبر فاجنر
جارتها الشرقيه
بالمناسبه صحيح ولكن هناك تعاون رغم
الانتقاد بين الجيشين بين الاحرار
الميليشيا والجيش الجزائري
ولا اعتقد ان الجزائر اليوم جاهزه وفي وضع
يسمح لها بان تعطي قواعد عسكريه في حين ان
المغرب
ليس هناك حاجه وتعطي قاعده عسكريه لدوله
فرضت نفسها فرضت نفوذها فاذا روسيا اليوم
ضعيفه مهزومه في اوكرانيا كيف تريدي ان
تعطيها هذه الهديه وهي لا تستحق ذلك يعني
لو كانت روسيا انتصرت وبرعت في حربها كانت
قوه يعني اثبتت جدارتها هذا ليس لذلك لن
يكون برايي اليوم
اي قاعده عسكريه روسيه في الجزائر ماذا عن
القاعده في المغرب قاعده امريكيه او حتى
ما تقول الجزائر انه ربما جديد على حدودها
نتحدث هنا عن تهديد اسرائيلي ربما حسب ما
تقوله السلطات الجزائريه السلطات
الجزائريه تقول ان اسرائيل متوغله في
المغرب والحقيقه ان التعاون المغربي
الاسرائيلي قوي جدا وهو سمح
بحصول
الموقف الامريكي في اخر زمن ترامب وهذا ما
دفع بعدد من الدول الاوروبيه
[موسيقى]
لاخذ بعين الاعتبار الموقف الامريكي
والبناء عليه فهناك يعني معيار
تاريخي حيث تكون المغرب تكون الاجزاء
الجزائر في مقابلها وحيث تكون الجزائر
يكون المغرب في الطرف الاخر فهذا المعيار
لن يختفي
ويتعزز يوما بعد يوم
واسف ان تكون الحدود المقفله بين الدولتين
الجارتين والشقيقتين هي ابعد اكثر بعد
تاريخي في العالم الحاضر وهي الحدود
المغربيه الجزائريه مقفله منذ سنه 94
عوده للسيد عمار صيغه ونفس السؤال الذي
طرحته على الدكتور بسبوسه علاقات
المتوتره كما نعلم بين المغرب والجزائر
وسواق التسلح بين الدولتين هل يمكن ان
يحكم توجهات الجزائر الدبلوماسيه
اذا بطبيعه الامر الجزائر حسمت مواقفها
خاصه في ظل هذا ربما الخلاف والتشنج
الموجود مع الطرف المغربي وبالتالي مباراه
الجزائر واقعيه ولها دلالتها بما يتعلق
بكلامه الامن القومي الجزائري خاصا وانه
هناك ربما شحنات هامه من التهريب المخدرات
الى الجزائر عبر الحدود الجزائريه وصولا
الى ربما الملف الاكثر
وهو ملف الغربيه الذي كل في كل مره طرف
المغربي بالتملص من مواجهه ربما القرارات
الامميه في ظل تسويه القضيه الصحراء
الغربيه في اطار مبادئ الامم المتحده
لن نعود عليه لكن السؤال هو هل يحدد توجه
شركات الجزائر
تقصدين شركه الجزائر مع الاطراف الغربيه
مع الاطراف الغربيه او مع موسكو
الجزائر ان هناك اصطفافا اكبر لصالح
المغرب من قبل الدول الاوروبيه او الغربيه
او حتى الولايات المتحده هل يمكن ان
يجعلها هذا ربما تبقي على شركتها وتعزز
شراكتها الاستراتيجيه مع موسكو
دول الغربيه مع المغرب هي ربما تحافظ فيها
على مسافه الامان مع مصالح الاقتصاديه في
الجزائر تدرك الدول العربيه تمام لادراك
ان مصالحها مع الجزائر اكثر وزنا من
مصالحها مع المغرب لماذا ربما علاقاتها مع
اختفافها الى جانب المغرب
الامور المتعلقه تمارس ضغوطها في الامريكي
او في الاتحاد الاوروبي وهذا ما بلد خلال
ربما
نتحدث عن العلاقات مع الولايات المتحده
هناك من يعتبر ان الولايات المتحده ترى في
الجزائر فعلا محوريا في المنطقه في الوقت
الراهن طيب يعني لماذا لا نرى مثلا سيجاره
للرئيس الجزائري الى واشنطن
بغض النظر عن زياره سيد الرئيس رئيس
الجمهوريه الى واشنطن الى غيرها الجزائر
تحافظ دوما على وزنها وعلى دافعيتها نحو
الاخرين
الجزائر تستقطب ولا توزع الادوار هي تستقب
دول الفاعله
الامر هو ربما حتى اذا كان ذهاب ذهاب في
ضرائف الجمهوريه شاركت الجزيره
مشاركه الجزائر
بوادر ما يسمى بشراكه في اطار مجموعه
البريد لها ربما دلالتها من الانهيار
السيد رئيس الجمهوريه الى موسكو وهذا كله
ربما يترجم هذا الموجود بين الجزائر انه
حتى
ربما التقارب بين الجزر والغرب له حدود هو
له ربما ضوابط
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده اقرب الى المغرب منها
الى الجزائر وليس هناك اي نوع من القطيعه
بين الدولتين هناك احترام متبادل الجزائر
لعبت في الماضي ادوار مهمه سواء في الحرب
العراقيه الايرانيه او في قضايا دوليه مثل
كارلوس وما الى هنالك لكن نعلم بان واشنطن
دائما ما تمارس سياسه الاستقطاب هل يمكن
ان نقول بانها فشلت حتى الان باستقطاب
الجزائر
تاريخ الجزائر هو قريب من موسكو
وليس عند واشنطن الامل في ان تتحول
الجزائر فجاه مثل ما عمل السداد سنه 77 في
طرد السوفيات
والاتجاه نحو واشطون هذا لن يحدث في
الجزائر شكرا لك دكتور انطوان بسبوس مدير
مرصد الدول العربيه في باريس واشكر
الدكتور عمار صيغه البحث في العلوم
السياسيه من الجزائر العاصمه وشكرا لكم مش
اهدينا على متابعه وجه
[موسيقى]